[Music]
this of course a segment where our
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far hundreds of challengers not one
winner we have never
made a mistake we don't make them yeah
yeah so tonight a fan named alexander
thinks he's caught a mistake he says it
happened last week when we celebrated
hanukkah by lighting our human centipede
hey conan on your show this entire week
you're lighting your human menorah
whatever thingy to help celebrate
hanukkah please join us for the
ceremonial lighting of the human
centipede menorah
[Applause]
happy fifth night of hanukkah everybody
[Applause]
but in fact you're doing something wrong
you're doing it backwards
you're supposed to light the menorah by
lighting the current night of hanukkah
and then going back a day to the
beginning so
you got that wrong
i'm sorry alexander but it is you sir
you
who's wrong
and i should know
you know a lot of people think i'm pure
irish but the truth is i'm only
255 256th
irish
the other one
256th is jewish
my great great great great great great
grandfather was rabbi elijah ben [ __ ]
zalman of vilna 18th century lithuania's
greatest rabbinical scholar here's his
picture as proof
thank you
[Music]
rabbi elijah wrote extensively about the
proper way to light the menorah based on
his study of the talmud the ancient book
of jewish learning i will now read from
the talmud rabbis please if you will
ah allow me to recite
on
the 25th of kislev are the days of
hanukkah which are eight the lights of
hanukkah are kindled from left to right
unless and this is very unlikely your
menorah is made from humans connected
mouth to tucuses
thank you
so the challenge still stands if you
think you've spotted an error on our
show which is highly unlikely
reported at teamcocoa.com haha i found
an error we will sort it out right here
on the air let's see if you've got what
it takes to make chump meat out of the
maestro